and I want to start with something that
I addressed during the radio side of PFT
now I want to get your thoughts on this
Chris the NBA has a draft lottery it
happens tonight Zion Williamson is the
prize right we just don't know who's
gonna win the lottery uh should the NFL
have a draft lottery I don't think so
I'm interested to hear like how you're
gonna sell this to me actually because
why do you think the NFL should well
because I think the NFL right now is the
most competitive sport in our country
it's very close between you know the
worst and best teams in the league and I
think it's set up the way where yeah I
like that the worst team in football
gets to pick towards the top of the
draft and get their pick of the litter
as far as the best players in the draft
but couldn't you take all the worst
teams in the league and and create some
sort of a system that would take away
the temptation to tank the whole purpose
of a draft lottery is to take away the
temptation and the opportunity to
deliberately lose games or in the hopes
of getting the best possible draft
position there's not a sport that teams
tank more than an NBA basketball so it
does it you're there I've won the case
no but I think tank in the NFL - yeah no
I know that gives my proposed guy go
ahead here's my problem as I was riffing
on this earlier one point I said just
take all 32 teams and put them in the
lottery who cares give you an equal shot
who cares then you completely eliminate
any temptation to tank because there's
no connection between how you do in a
given season and where you land in the
draft but I decided to revise okay thank
you Hicks 21 through 32 will be
determined based upon how you finish in
the postseason the playoff teams you
super win the Super Bowl your last you
get knocked out in the wild card round
you have the worst record your first of
the 21 to 30 - okay top 20 teams
yeah draft the teams that don't make it
to the playoffs right straight lottery
yeah no weighted the way they do in the
NBA no you didn't make it to playoffs
you are in contention for the first
overall pick and they'll determine the
order of round one based upon the
outcome of that lottery and you make it
a two night television if that is the
team that's worse though have more you
know balls by equal equal that is
insanity equal absolutely because
because there's it there's still an
incentive to tank if you get more balls
well I yeah okay but there's no one sent
into the tank for any coach or GM out
there compact your I understand they
might down this road so many times your
honor it's about the owner
okay the owner is the one who initiates
the tank right
how's he going down on the field and
going hey quarterback don't do no hey
don't Cortese whoa he's going to the
coaching the GM saying I think we should
see what the rookie quarterback looks
like I think we should see how the
undrafted you that the teams that are
doing that and the owners that are doing
that are probably not good football
teams the Tempe Buccaneers did it in
2015 right and during a game well I
don't know there haven't been very good
so I don't know what they did it you
know okay yeah maybe well at the end of
the year we feel like they did it
towards the end of the year where they
just work out okay we're not having a
good year let's lose a few more and it's
not again where I don't think coaches
are tanking in these incidences or the
players are actually trying to lose
games
yeah the GM the coach they might be
putting out younger guys that don't give
them the best opportunity to win the
game but there's still an end goal there
you not acknowledged how can you not
acknowledge as a temptation to tank
because I've been in NFL teams where we
work for an 11 and we're going to last
it's not here and I got here okay
there's no temptation for the player to
tank you want to win I know when there's
nothing for the conversation no but
there's an organizational temptation to
tank I I look at basketball you've
admitted they tank and basketball hang
on you've admitted the tank in
basketball yeah the players aren't
deliberately playing like crap right
right the coaches aren't deliberately
coaching like crap yeah they're putting
crappy players out there right right and
then and I still don't know if I'm all
in on an NBA basketball too I just
wanted to prove you wrong but yeah again
I get it that the front office CEO and
owners they might want a better pick or
whatever it is but yeah I just don't
their coaches and players are gonna
compete so yeah you're tanking to a
degree but I can't just flat-out call it
tanking when the guys that are out there
responsible for the outcome are playing
hard and the coaches are playing hard
and - your lottery thing with 20 teams
being all involved in that that is
ludicrous
I mean why because it'd be their playoff
team he ran out of play well the
Pittsburgh Steelers you're gonna give
them the number one pick of the draft if
they win the lottery that's insane
that's just stupid I don't know what
else to say the the problem with doing
the weighted lottery yeah
is that it doesn't completely remove the
incentive the tag and I think the reason
the NFL won't do a draft lottery because
what a great offseason tentpole event
that would it would be I got that the
NFL won't do it I believe they don't
want to acknowledge the disconnect
between integrity the game try to win
every game
and the value of being the team that has
the first pick in the draft because
there's clearly value the higher you
pick the better it every time there's a
trade up and you see what they give up
to trade up you realize hey it is better
to be bad so so they if they start down
that path the only way they could pull
it off and not suggest that there's any
legitimacy to the idea of tanking is
make it a straight lottery that's the
only way they can do it because if it is
weighted they're acknowledging you
benefit from being bad right we don't
want to acknowledge that you benefit
from being bad you do we just don't want
to acknowledge it I think that's why
they don't do a draft law yeah well it
may be but you know also you know again
I'd like the NFL's current system where
the NFL's King in this country for a
reason and I think this is one of the
reasons because of the competitive
balance and you know again most p.m. the
competitive balance of Patriots win
every suit well hey this is a special
team but certainly we see a big rotation
of other teams that are competing for it
on a yearly basis but you know when you
get done are you done texting now are
you done you good sometimes sometimes
there's situations where we're at work
what are you like a renegade are you
Antonio Brown over here this is not
England Patriots I know my wife wanted
to know if I wanted to have breakfast
and I said no I'm gonna eat with you so
now go screw yourself I'll breakfast my
wife bastard sorry Jill I like Jill I
don't want it her to eat alone but Jill
you don't want to eat with this guy
anyways go you by yourself what were you
talking about
I don't know people think that the
lotteries rigged in the NBA anyways
that's what I'm saying so you can't win
sometimes in any scenario you set up
you